Je ne pourrais pas m'appeler Helena, je suis Jesse, ajouter une
dysphorie de genre, mais ce n'était pas quelque chose auquel je
pensais tout le temps jusqu'à ce que je
le voie sur les réseaux sociaux. J'avais 15 ans quand
j'ai appris pour la première fois qu'une fille
pouvait devenir  garçon et j'ai découvert
cela sur les réseaux sociaux aussi comme j'ai toujours euh
j'avais beaucoup de problèmes avec mon poids et
j'avais beaucoup de problèmes juste avec le fait d'être
comme grandir une fille que je regarderais
comme des garçons et voir qu'ils n'ont pas '  Je n'avais pas
ce genre de problème de poids que
j'avais et je devenais juste très jaloux
et ensuite je commençais à détester les
parties féminines de mon corps Je suis venu voir mes
parents quand j'avais quinze ans en tant que trans et
je devais juste je harcelé  les a harcelés et les a
suppliés de me laisser
prendre des hormones jusqu'à ce qu'ils acceptent quand
j'avais 17 ans et j'étais à six mois de mon
18e anniversaire, j'avais 18 ans et j'ai pu
obtenir légalement de la testostérone euh nous avons tous les deux
obtenu des hormones par formulaire de consentement  clinique,
ce qui signifie que vous n'avez besoin d'aucun type de
thérapie, allez-y et signez un
p  aper
Je considère essentiellement la testostérone comme une sorte
de chose qui enlèverait la douleur dans
ma vie comme si cela me ferait ne pas détester
mon corps, cela me rendrait
peut-être plus social ou quelque chose comme ça,
obtenir une seconde chance dans la vie en
devenant le contraire  le sexe et je n'étais pas je
n'ai pas eu comme des changements comme je
pensais que je le ferais dont vous savez que nous sommes
vraiment comme une partie de comme cette
illusion qui comme je pourrais juste devenir
comme quelque chose d'impossible juste ces
problèmes originaux comme la haine de soi
les problèmes corporels sont revenus
et c'était comme à chaque étape que je franchissais
vers la transition, je serais heureux
pendant un moment, mais finalement les
problèmes reviendraient et à un
moment donné, je suis devenu si misérable que j'ai
juste regardé en arrière sur ma vie  et je viens de
voir que prendre de la testostérone et faire
une transition médicale n'était pas le
bon choix pour gérer
mes problèmes émotionnels pourquoi voulais-je être
un homme, vous savez ce que je n'aimais pas
tant d'être une femme où  est-ce que ça
vient et pourquoi je me détestais
tellement quand j'avais 15 ans que je ne voulais
plus être moi-même, j'ai dû trouver
ce genre de presque alter ego et
donc quand j'étais chevalier et que j'ai parlé
avec mon partenaire et pendant environ six
mois, je me suis demandé si je voulais vraiment
faire la transition, c'est comme une nouvelle
phase de dysphorie de genre jusqu'à ce que finalement,
au cours de mon semestre de printemps de deuxième année, j'ai
décidé que non, c'est tout, je vais sur
hormones je '  je reviens à aimer elle / ses
pronoms j'ai fini et j'ai utilisé la
testostérone pendant environ 17 mois et
quand j'avais 19 ans j'ai réalisé
que c'était une erreur et j'ai arrêté d'utiliser
cette testostérone